on March 17th the Academy held a very  special dinner at the Beverly Hilton  Hotel and here with highlights of that  evening is someone with countless  credits as an actress and a brand new  one as an author a woman who to this day  will not step into a shower without a  security guard miss Janet Lee award  dinner where we took the opportunity to  present two additional awards the first  is named for Gordon East Sawyer who  established standards of technical  excellence which tonight's recipient  typifies mr. Lyne reads - done  well I thank you so much for this very  great honor it is certainly a thrill and  I really extend my thanks to the  scientific or technical awards committee  of the Academy god bless you all  because special achievement award for  sound effects editing of the liver his  payroll  this is one unbelievably wonderful the  fulfillment of a long time dream that  goes back to that person movie I ever  saw  thank you all fulfilling that dream